hi this is presh talwalkar
in this video i'm going to go over some
comparison shopping math so that you can
get the best value when you're shopping
at the supermarket
all the examples in this video are based
on prices i saw on my recent trip to the
supermarket
so let's do a first example
let's say you're buying toilet paper and
one package has 24 rolls for 6.99
and another package has 72 rolls for
17.99
which option is cheaper
i'm going to explain a method so that
you can figure this out in your head
very quickly
the first step is you should round the
numbers to the nearest dollar
because that'll be good enough for our
estimation purposes
the next step is i want you to get the
two quantities equal
and the method we're going to use is
we're going to scale up the smaller size
so in this case 24 rolls is the smaller
size
and we're going to scale this up until
it's 72 rolls
so if we buy one package we get 24 rolls
if we buy two packages we're going to
get 48 rolls and it will be a cost of 14
if we buy third package we'll end up
with 72 rolls for a cost of 21.
and that brings us to step three
which is now we have two quantities of
72 rolls
and we simply need to pick the one which
is cheaper
so it's very obvious that
72.72 rolls for eighteen dollars is the
better value
so in this case seventy two rolls for
eighteen dollars is better than twenty
four rolls
for seven dollars
let's do another example
let's say you're shopping for oatmeal
and one container has 18 ounces for 1.49
and another package has 42 ounces for
2.99
which package offers the better
we'll go through our three-step process
we'll first round the numbers
to an even amount
because that will be good enough for
estimation purposes
then we'll scale up the smaller size
so if we buy two packages of the 18
ounces
oatmeal
we'll end up with 36 ounces of oatmeal
for three dollars
now in this case we don't have
the exact same quantity for both
packages in one case we have 36 ounce
and in another we have 42.
however what we do have is we have the
same dollar amount
for two
different amounts of oatmeal so would
you rather get 36 ounces for three
dollars or 42 ounces
the answer is easy you're going to want
to pick the one which is giving you more
oatmeal for three dollars so in this
case 42 ounces is a better value
in a third example let's say you have 10
ounces of potato chips for 1.99
or 16 ounces for 2.99
is cheaper
we'll first go ahead and round the
numbers
then we'll try scaling up the smaller
size
so if we buy two packages of the 10
ounce potato chips we'll end up with 20
ounces for four dollars
now unfortunately
unlike our other examples
neither the quantity
matches nor the dollar amounts match so
we cannot directly compare
20 ounces of potato chips versus 16
ounces
so we're going to need to do something
different
what we'll do is we'll figure out the
unit cost for the 10 ounce package of
potato chips
so if ten ounces cost two dollars
that means every ounce of potato chips
in that package costs 20 cents
and now what we'll do is we'll scale
that up to 16 ounces
so buying 10 ounces for two dollars
is basically the same as buying 16
ounces at a rate of three dollars and 20
cents
now we can compare the two options
and
we can conclude that buying the 16 ounce
package of potato chips for three
dollars is the better value
let's do a final example of soda pop
you have two options one is a two liter
bottle for one dollar
the other is 24 cans for 5.99
which option is the better value
we'll go ahead and round the number 599
now instead of scaling up directly we're
going to need to convert some units
because the 2-liter bottle is based on
the metric system
and the 24 cans are based in ounces
so how can we convert ounces
into liters
well luckily
if you take any can of soda
it's already written on there a 12 ounce
can of soda is roughly equal to 355
milliliters or 0.355 liters
so doing a little bit of math
that means 1 liter is roughly 2.8 12
ounce cans
or a 2 liter bottle is roughly 5.6 cans
so now we're comparing the options of
5.6 cans for a dollar versus 24 cans for
six dollars
and we can go ahead and scale up the
smaller size
so if we buy
four two liter bottles that's roughly
getting twenty two and a half cans for
four dollars
we finally need to pick the cheaper
option
so in this case once again neither the
quantities nor the dollar amounts
exactly match
but you can see that on with the 2-liter
bottle
you're basically paying the rate of 22
and a half cans for four dollars
which is almost 24 cans
so the question is for about 24 cans do
you want to pay six dollars or do you
want to pay four dollars
and it's obvious the cheaper option here
is the two liter bottle
so
i wanted to include this example because
it's not always the case that buying in
bulk is going to be cheaper
i hope you like this video
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory you can
also check me out on my blog mind your
decisions or on twitter at
preshtalwalker